[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette table ronde
marquant l'ouverture de l'édition 2020
du sky business des tables rondes à
suivre sur le site de l'événement bien
sûr et sur terré 78 plateau avec moi
jean michel fourgous bonjour résidence
de saint quentin en yvelines nous avons
également en ligne par visio alexandra
dublanche bonjour à vous vous êtes
bonjour vous êtes vice présidente ile de
france chargée du développement
économique notamment gérard bacheliers
bonjour bonjour m'entendais très bien
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles et dans un
instant c'est à zachary a redit le
président du medef yvelines qui va nous
rejoindre pour commencer jean michel
fourgous maintenir cette convention
d'affaires même en ligne c'était
essentiel je rappelle que c'est la
cinquième édition et que ce sera donc
100% virtuel c'est est essentiel de
savoir s'adapter réagir et maintenir ce
lien celui entre les entreprises écoutez
c'est indispensable de soutenir
massivement nos entrepreneurs je vous le
rappelle c'est eux qui sont sur le
terrain de guerre entre guillemets c'est
une véritable guerre c'était une
mancelle sanitaires
donc bien sûr alors ça c'est le premier
événement de networking qui était un des
plus importants en france en digital
donc c'est une très bonne initiative
donc merci surtout à tous nos
partenaires sans qui qui qui qui sont de
l'entreprise qui ont tous cette culture
qui ont compris que bien sûr nos
entrepreneurs c'est nos vedettes c'est
nos héros assez surtout en ce moment
donc puis bien sûr leur rappelaient des
entrepreneurs que plutôt que d'aller
prospecter à new york sur fond
simplement rayé voulait déjà commencé à
prospecter les dix sept mille
entreprises connaissent sur notre
territoire en se faisant accompagner
bien sûr par la région qui fait un
formidable travail mais sûr je remercie
il décrète alexandre a dû blanche mais
turquie qui sont à nos côtés et qui ont
des moyens bien sûr supérieur on a déjà
assez importante mais je veux dire que
mon des moyens bien sûr mais ils savent
les utiliser
voilà il est vrai on les remercie je
peux vous dire on a on a été un sacré
paquet l'entreprise pas tout
malheureusement vraie fausse et je
prétends jamais ce bien sûr sauver tout
le monde mais bien entendu on vit un
moment extrêmement c'est vraiment
presque man de guerre nos grands parents
l'ont connue nous nous on connait une
autre forme
donc on a 400 entreprises qui sont
connectés donc avec nous il ya déjà 1000
rendez vous d'affaires qui sont
programmés donc voilà tout ça va dans le
bon sens
je peux vous dire et puis bien sûr nous
nous partenaires aussi à mercedes
société générale la french tech paris 7
les meilleures initiatives saint-quentin
tv sony gîte merci aussi le medef je
sais donc notre ami zachari vla la cci
donc merci l'ami gérard bien sûr et tous
les réseaux d'entrepreneurs delta ce qui
convergent secrétaires donc voilà
beaucoup de une mobilisation générale
qui naturellement ne de ne peut pas
paralyser tous les facteurs négatifs
qu'on a pu prendre depuis le début de
cette année mais il ya quand même il ya
quand même une ouverture il faut le dire
aussi
honnêtement aujourd'hui on commence à
voir le bout du tunnel tout de même il y
a trois vaccins faut dire qu'ils sont
quand même aujourd'hui plébiscités par
la communauté internationale on peut pas
ne pas le citer
maintenant à nous tous avec la région et
le département avec saint quentin on est
en train de préparer une accélération de
la diffusion du vaccin pour l'instant
lapin mais je peux vous dire que on va
essayer d'accélérer ça parce que il faut
pas qu'il y ait trop de délai entre le
premier servi le dernier servi voilà en
tout cas la bagarre sur laquelle on se
bat alors bien sûr de suivre aussi les
trésoreries qui vivent un moment
difficile
aussi cet endettement aussi qu' aussi
augmentent auprès de nos entreprises
voilà ce que je peux vous dire ce soir
il y aura alexandra rosetti neutre notre
vice présidente l'économique qui
clôturera qui donnera les résultats de
cette journée donc surtout les 118 voilà
un peu ce que sur les grandes lignes
en tout cas la mobilisation est générale
à saint quentin
nos entrepreneurs sont notre priorité
c'est pas c'est pas n'importe quoi oui
je rappelle que haut niveau la guerre
sanitaire lundi marc pardon mardi et
mercredi 1er et 2 décembre
on est une opération anti qu'ovide donc
en termes de santé au vélodrome
on a donc près de trois mille tests dits
génique qui sont prêts pour tout le
monde bien entendu
donc voilà les différentes actions qui
sont en cours et surtout on regarde ces
vaccins et en continuant à accompagner
nos entrepreneurs business day qui
débute donc aujourd'hui qui débute en ce
moment en direct si vous nous suivez
notamment sur tv 78 jean michel fourgous
vous avez évoqué alexandra rosetti elle
interviendra effectivement à 18h aussi
sur cette antenne pour faire un bilan de
cette édition donc 100% virtuel avec des
échanges qui vont se maintenir tout au
long de la journée et là je vous renvoie
vers le site internet de l événement du
sky business day j'ai donné quelques
noms tout de même de grands groupes et
plus petits groupes aussi qui
participent à cet événement thales
renault société générale le nôtre kpmg
ou encore mercedes pour les groupes le
plus important et puis à 2 les âges
expansion vidal auto auxi boss auxi box
et gennari ce groupe pour les plus
petites il y en a bien d'autres qui
participent vous avez a mentionné ces
quelques 500 600 entreprises qui sont
qui sont inscrits encore cette année
nous allons échanger sur le contexte
actuel sur la nécessité aussi pour les
différents acteurs pour mieux rebondir
et je salue aussi au passage de hakkari
hardy qui nous a rejoint pour cette
table ronde
bonjour à vous brendon du medef 78
juste avant de vous entendre les uns et
les autres nous allons écouter un
message de valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région ile de france
elle ne pouvait pas être présente avec
nous mais elle tenait intervenir on
l'écouté on se retrouve juste après
mesdames et messieurs chers amis je suis
désolé de ne pas être physiquement
présent pour le ski business day mais ce
n'est que partie remise à un moment où
nous pourrons à nouveau nous déplacer je
voudrais rendre hommage à jean michel
fourgous le président de saint quentin
en yvelines qui je le sais a mis au
coeur de son projet le développement
économique la crise économique qui va
nous toucher avec la pandémie va être
extrêmement rude et c'est pour cela que
nous devons nous relever ensemble nous
relever ensemble ça veut dire que la
région sera très puissamment investi aux
côtés du tissu économique pour aider à
faire rebondir nos entreprises faire
rebondir nos entreprises grâce au fonds
de solidarité
vous le savez peut-être mais dans les
yvelines
ce sont aujourd'hui trente mille 600
entreprises qui ont bénéficié du fonds
de solidarité est à région
et puis nous avons les prêts rebond des
prêts pour les pme qui sont accordées
par la région avec l'aide de bpi est là
aussi
367 entreprises ont pu demander ces
prêts rebond jusqu'à 300 mille euros et
puis nous avons un fonds résilience se
font résilience il est pour les plus
petits et les plus fragiles d'entre vous
pour les auto-entrepreneurs les
indépendants les tpe les pme jusqu'à 20
salariés 50 salariés dans l'hôtellerie
et la restauration et sans nombre de
salariés pour l'économie sociale et
solidaire se font résilience ce sont des
aides en trésorerie de 3000 à cent mille
euros qui sont attribués en partenariat
par la région et saint quentin en
yvelines
l'intercommunalité travaillent la main
dans la main avec la région
ile de france comme les 71
intercommunalités d'île de france
d'angers déjà pour la casse qui s'est 54
entreprises qui ont pu bénéficier de
l'aide résilience et puis il y a aussi
les chèques numérique ces chèques
numérique de 1500 euros que nous avons
mis en place dès le printemps pour tous
nos commerces pour tous nos artisans qui
voudraient prendre le tournant du
numérique
c'est ed ce chèque numérique s'est
révélé évidemment très important dans
cette période de second confinement
puisqu'elle a permis à des dizaines des
centaines de commerces dans les yvelines
de se transférer sur internet et la
région ile de france a mis en place une
plate forme globale mais commerce point
il de france.fr avec son local de façon
à ce que chaque francilien puisse
retrouver ces commerces de proximité en
ligne et puissent avoir accès à leurs
sites web puissent avoir accès au click
and collect à la vente à emporter
digital alors oui la région et mobiliser
tous azimuts pour ces entreprises et
nous préparons la relance la relance
c'est investir dans les secteurs
d'avenir c'est relocaliser des
productions s'est diversifié ces
réinvestir et nous avons aidé toute une
série d'entreprises à deux moments
d'abord toute une série d'entreprises
qui ont investi dans des productions
indispensable pour lutter contre le coc
vide les productions indispensable de
souveraineté sanitaires il y en a ici à
saint quentin en yvelines
ce sont les deux entreprises bertin
technologie basée à montigny qui grâce à
la région développera un kit de
détection rapide du coc vide ou alors
here in space basé à elancourt qui
développe des unités mobiles de
décontamination de l'air elles ont
bénéficié du plan pme qu'aux vide de la
région
qui prévoyait des subventions jusqu'à
huit cent mille euros
et puis après ce plan pme qu'aux vide
nous avons généralisé notre soutien avec
pme relance pme relance industrielle
l'objectif c'est de réindustrialiser
l'île de france
mais évidemment en allant vers la
troisième révolution industrielle la
révolution numérique
la transition écologique oui nous avons
besoin de cette ré industrialisation et
7 réindustrialisation elle se concrétise
ici à saint quentin en yvelines je peux
citer trois entreprises parmi les 18 qui
ont été aidés dans notre département qui
sont situées dans l'agglomération
c'est le laboratoire de recherche franck
lab qui travaille sur du matériel
médical et qui va aménager un nouveau
site de production les moderniser son
laboratoire d'analysé de recherche ou
encore la société gamme et cas gamme et
cas société industrielle qui fait des
pièces de précision pour la robotique
pour l'automobile qui va se moderniser
et investir dans des équipements pour
diversifier son offre
ou bien mécanique atelier à coignières
alors vous le voyez nous passons à la
vitesse supérieure nous transformons
outil productif régional
et puis nous avons une aide qui
s'adresse à toutes les pme avec un
guichet unique
cette aide c'est innov'up innov'up c'est
pour chacun d'entre vous chacune des tpe
et les pme d'île de france qui souhaite
innover et qui souhaitent bénéficier de
l'aide de la région
vous voyez toutes ces aides voulais
retrouver sur le site de la région ile
de france
elles sont pour vous elles sont pour
vous aider à rebondir pour que nous
relevions ensemble merci à tous merci de
m'avoir écouté merci d'avoir m'avoir
donné l'occasion de vous présenter tout
ce soutien et toute cette aide d'une
région puissamment investi dans le
développement économique comme les saint
quentin en yvelines
merci donc à valérie pécresse la
présidente de région de retour sur le
plateau de tv soixante dix huit pour
l'ouverture de ce sky business day à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines durant les
prochaines minutes 45 prochaines minutes
nous allons parler de la collaboration
entreprises territoires indispensable
pour relancer l économie en cette
période de crise inédite alexandra
double hanche me tourne vers vous tout
d'abord vice-présidente de la région
bien sûr je reprécise que chacun peut
intervenir n'hésitez pas à vous signaler
aujourd'hui l'île de france est affirmée
aussi comme chef de file pour venir en
aide aux entreprises il ya des
financements il ya de la coordination
aussi on a pu le comprendre à travers
l'intervention de valérie pécresse tout
à fait alors que la première fois dans
une crise économique que les deux france
est la région la plus touchée est la
plus touchée de par la structuration de
son tissu quand on est la première
région touristique mondiale est
forcément que les frontières ferme pour
la 14 millions de touristes en moins et
6 milliard de pertes forcément sur un
impact massif sur toute la filière
économique il ya un lot restaurateurs
sont très touchées puisque cet été
notamment aussi tout le monde a fui
l'île de france quand d'autres régions
se rattraper un petit peu on est aussi
la première région aéronautique de
france des régions automobiles de france
francis d'arles dans les yvelines
et donc ces secteurs là aussi sont
impactés pour la 75% de dilution du
trafic mondial aérien donc tout ça pour
dire qu'on est effectivement dans une
situation difficile et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a dû redoubler de
d'agilité de réactivité de créativité
aussi pour inventer de nouveaux
dispositifs en lien avec tous les
partenaires dont certains sont sur le
plateau aujourd'hui et à ce jour on peut
affirmer qu'on a et d en ile de france
qu'elle semblait l'entreprise s'appelait
une entreprise sur trois arcs tous les
différents dispositifs et au titre seul
de la région c'est à peu près de 450
millions d'euros mobilisés pour aider
pour aider ces entreprises
donc je tiens à préciser puisque on le
pose souvent la question que si on est
capable de mettre autant d'argent sur la
table c'est aussi parce que on l'a une
gestion financière saine quand tout
allait bien ce qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'avoir une crédibilité
financière qui nous permet d'emprunter
sur les marchés quand certaines régions
peut mettre en difficulté
et ne pas avoir des plans de relance
aussi importants puisque le plan de
relance de la jeune de france c'est un
milliard 3 donc évidemment pour
l'économie pour la formation
aussi pour répondre aux difficultés
sociales et toutes les thématiques de
transition énergétique
donc je pense que voilà on fait évoluer
les dispositifs au fur et à mesure la
présidente vient de les détailler
l'agilité la réussite et ça a été
vraiment la clé on l'a vu mais des
collectivités locales ont été les plus à
même de vraiment répondre en temps et en
oeuvre ou besoin
l'éloquence rendez compte que le sportif
il y avait un manque par exemple qu'il
fallait élargir pour les restaurateurs
puisque évidemment elles sont six
national ne s'adresse pas aux
difficultés
il suffit par mme de l'île de france où
forcément là des loyers plus important
en armes plus de salariés dans des
grands restaurants notamment interdits
eh bien on s'adaptait la présidente
décide dès le lendemain souhaitez goûter
ista je pense que ça a été très
appréciée par un parole tous nos
interlocuteurs
je ne vais pas redonné toute la liste
des z qui sont mis en place par la
région le site internet de la région le
le fait très bien mais je peux citer le
fond résilience cette avance
remboursable à taux zéro de 3000 à
100000 euros
là le plan relance industrie aussi aide
en subvention plafonnée
le prêt redon prêt à taux zéro aussi
pour renforcer cette fameuse trésorerie
des tpe pme
du côté de saint quentin en yvelines
aussi à toute une série de dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place pour répondre à
cette crise un million et demi d'euros
débloqués renforcement du fonds
initiative sky une exonération des
loyers et redevances pour les structures
aux six occupants des locaux à saint
quentin en yvelines mise en place a tout
récemment d'un marketplace aussi en
ligne est-ce qu'on peut revenir avec
vous jean michel fourgous un peu sur le
les succès de ces dispositifs et puis
sur l'adaptation rapide aussi à chaque
fois des territoires tout simplement
face aux situations inédites
oui là je rajoute donc pour les
commerçants
ils peuvent mettre sans référence par un
magasin sur shopping ce qui je crois
qu'ils sont tous moon en courant pour
saint quentin qui permet donc de vendre
un peu en commerce banque dans ses
moments difficiles vont d'abord me
remerciez effectivement la région pour
les moyens qui ont été débloqués fait
qu' on a même été surpris qu'il faut
trouver moyen cela dit donc merci et
surtout pour leur réactivité
donc ça veut dire que culturellement ils
ont compris ce que c'est bien bosser
quand on est au niveau des grandes
structures de fer déclarations mais là
concrètement nous envoyer les moyens à
arriver et les réponses très vite la
rapidité dans seulement là quand on voit
le niveau de souffrance me sur nos
acteurs économiques aulas donc dont
alors on continue en synergie avec tous
nos actes et on se félicite bien sûr on
sait que d'avoir des acteurs là
territoriaux on l'a vu c'est important
on prépare aussi la propre génération je
vous dise un pour les vaccins mais c'est
important
bien sûr d'avoir d'être dans des
structures je sais que j'ai des autres
collègues amer d'un méchant dans
d'autres régions ou cci voilà il ya est
sûr que l'ile-de-france a été
particulier touché alexandra la raison
de la pluie mais en même temps la
réponse a été aussi avec des moyens et
on s'en félicite même si on peut pas
sauver tout le monde faut pas se leurrer
je le vois je
il ya des gens qui quittent en plus bien
sûr qu'on ait besoin de communiquer par
aussi en numérique ixair et on sent
toutefois que c'est un peu plus dans
certains métiers donc on les aide et les
mêmes il faut qu on est vraiment sur le
terrain encore plus parce que voilà on
met mais globalement franchement dans
une crise pareille on a limité
on a largement limité la casse et on se
prépare maintenant à la phase suivante
et le travail se fait en commun aussi
avec la région il ya un partenariat qui
ce qui se met qui se met en place
c'est aussi important et ça permet de
souligner qu'il ya une adaptation des
territoires aussi et une importance que
ce soit les territoires agglomération
région qui réagissent et pas forcément
attendre que ce soit l'état il faut
s'adapter aux particularités locales
aussi douce et l'étaler trop lourd il
est trop lent il est trop cher
tout le monde le sait bon heureusement
effectivement que les collectivités du
goût les collectifs bien sûr ont un rôle
d'autant plus important alors à main il
faut améliorer ça mais celui qui est
capable de réformer l'état vous ne vous
ne venez pas ce que ça fait 20 ans que
j'entends ça voilà mais en tout cas les
collectivités elles sont là nous avons
aussi le représentant du jour le disait
du medef des yvelines de la chambre de
commerce de versailles avec nous
aujourd'hui les entreprises sur le
terrain est ce qu'elles ont le sentiment
justement qu'on répond à leurs besoins
aussi et sinon aussi qu'attendent tel va
commencer avec vous gerra bacheliers
pour la cci
oui je pense que les comme ça vient des
dix lits à des grandes difficultés sur
le territoire en dehors des commerces de
première nécessité ou des grandes
surfaces je crois que toutes les
entreprises sont touchées par cette
crise sanitaire et c'est un événement
important et je crois que les aides et
dispositifs qui ont été mises en place
sont à la hauteur que ce soit les
dispositifs d'état et les dispositifs de
la région vous avez cité je crois que
tout le monde a cité les dispositifs que
sont le fonds de solidarité le fond
résigne ans le prêt rebonds et puis les
la possibilité du chômage partiel qui
avait été mise en place
mais tout ça ce sont aussi ceux ne sont
aussi que des amortisseurs c'est à dire
que il faut pas qu il le fait que à
terme on aura quand même des des
entreprises qui vont être en grande
difficulté une fois que tous ces
amortisseurs seront terminés que
l'activité normale va reprendre et je je
suppose que cette activité normale va
reprendre assez rapidement et on a sur
le territoire quand même des structures
qui sont très touchées on à dire les
filières automobile et
au nautic leçons des filières importante
avec beaucoup de sous-traitants qui
souffrent et je crois que on a déjà en
nombre de sociétés qui souffre justement
actuellement sur le territoire soit qui
change de territoire soit qui vont
disparaître
donc il faut les aider pour les aider
les accompagner et donc les petites les
plus petites en particulier c'est la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie a mis
en place une cellule d'urgence
on l'avait d'amis en place le 1er
confinement de cellule d'urgence j'ai
redonné numérotés de 01 55 65 44 deux
fois il y as depuis depuis deux semaines
à salon de l'entreprise qui appelle
cette cellule d'urgence on a à peu près
1500 par jour et on se rend compte que
la difficulté bien sûr les difficultés
importantes ce sont des difficultés de
trésorerie et que les chefs d'entreprise
sont quand même dans une situation
psychologique difficile très difficile
puisque les entretiens sont assez long
avec les conseillers de la chambre donc
on se rend compte qu'il ya vraiment une
situation difficile pour les chefs
d'entreprise
je voudrais citer aussi une structure
qui est importante sur le territoire
acquis et qui est pas suffisamment
connue c'est le centre d'information et
de prévention qui est présent dans les
yvelines et qui est donc à la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et qui est une
structure en toute confidentialité qui
est de justement les chefs d'entreprises
qui sont en grande difficulté qui peut
les orienter vers les différentes
structures qui peuvent les aider et en
particulier actuellement en train de
mettre en place un réseau dead du avec
aussi des tuteurs qui pourraient
accompagner justement ces chefs
d'entreprises en difficulté tout
autrement pour leur permettre justement
de sortir de ses difficultés
la chambre de commerce a mis en place
aussi ans membre de deux dispositifs et
le dernier dispositif je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de deux places de marché qui
sont en train de se mettre en route sur
le territoire j'en suis ravi parce que
je pense qu'il aurait fallu que ces
places de marché existe déjà
lors du premier confinement
malheureusement c'est lors du deuxième
confinement qu'on ait mis en place en
ami ans
las une place de marché qui s'appelle la
place de noël ma place de noël qui est
une place éphémère qui permet aux
commerçants donc de présenter leurs
produits de vendre leurs produits
et c'est un accord que l'on a avec la
poste qui permet justement aussi une
livraison
c'est sur la base de la plate forme ma
ville mon shopping et cette plateforme
éphémère va permettre justement aux
commerçants jusqu'au 31 décembre de
pouvoir vendre les stocks parce que on
sait aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de stock
chez les commerçants et qu'ils ont
besoin de bande très rapidement dans
toutes les places de marché qui existe
en je dirais les bienvenus et j'espère
que ces places de marché vont vont
continuer à exister et que les
commerçants vont aussi utiliser au
maximum cet aspect numérique et cette
possibilité justement de vendre sur des
places de marché même si lorsque cette
crise sanitaire sera terminé et qu'ils
ont la possibilité justement de vendre
et j'espère qu'ils resteront justement
avec cette co jp demande sur les places
de marché
le conseil régional justement les aides
avec le chèque numérique
ça a été cité tout à l'heure par la
présidente le chèque numérique de 1500
euros et la c6 est porteur justement de
cette opération de cette aide sur le
territoire est de plus en plus les
commerçants en l'air d'être intéressées
justement par par cette aide et j'en
suis ravi du côté du medef on vous
l'avez entendu pour les entreprises il
ya de nombreuses dispositifs qui
existent au et si malgré tout vous
exprimer quelques fois des inquiétudes
aussi en a certaines qui passent entre
les mailles des nombreux dispositifs on
peut parler de ces entreprises de taille
intermédiaire bonjour à tous c'est vrai
tout a été dit le président jean michel
fourgous a expliqué effectivement les
différents gel qui ont été alloués aux
entreprises
valérie pécresse que je remercie
infiniment et alexandre dublanche
franchement je tiens à saluer l'action
de la région très efficace
très proche du terrain très proche des
entreprises est encore une fois
1000mercis ce qu'il faudrait dire c'est
que il ya une perte d'activité autour de
12% aujourd'hui les différents
dispositifs qui ont été utilisés ni en
place ont aidé énormément d'entreprises
mais comme vous l'avez dit wilfried il y
a des trous dans la raquette notamment
les entreprises au delà de 55 ans se
sont très belles de dei c'est vraiment
l'excellence française qui est
aujourd'hui qui est au dessus des seuils
et qui ne bénéficie pas de beaucoup d
aide
il ne faut pas qu'on perde ce savoir
faire il ne faut pas qu'on perde ses
perles je dirais de notre industrie et
de notre économie
il est vrai que il ya certains secteurs
qui sont impactés par la crise je pense
à la grande distribution je pense aux
digital je pense à l'agroalimentaire à
la chimie mais il est vrai que il y en a
certains qui souffrent énormément comme
l'industrie automobile ils gérard ma
cheville et lady il y aller' nautique
évidemment il ya des grossistes
alimentaires qui souffrent avec la
fermeture des restaurants des hôtels etc
etc
il y a également les réseaux d'agencés
immobilières que pendant le confinement
ils sont totalement bloqués ils ne
peuvent pas fonctionner donc si vous
voulez il y a
quelques réajustements à faire il faut
surtout comprendre une chose bénéficier
des aides ça n'est pas le fonctionnement
normal de l'entreprise une entreprise
souhaite vraiment qu'elle puisse
fonctionner et qu'elles puissent
engranger du chiffre d'affaires et
qu'elle puisse comment dirais-je
commerciale et ses clients il faut
savoir que le climat des affaires a
considérablement souffert
nous avons par exemple nous avons fait
une petite mutuelle et nous constatons
qu'il y a à peu près 27 % des
entreprises des entrepreneurs à part
donc on envisager d'arrêter pour vous
dire l'impact sur le l'état d'esprit des
des des entrepreneurs nous avons le
commerce de commerce qui est pris dans
un étau les taux qu'on appellerait nous
les taux français
il est vrai que la france seule
l'angleterre a établi cette distinction
l'italie également dans des embrouilles
l'allemagne a plutôt favorisé une
ouverture de commerces de gros et de
détail des protocoles
ils ont exigé des protocoles sanitaires
strictes et ils ont exigé qu'il y ait à
peu près 10 mètres carrés par client
l'espagne fermeture des établissements à
22h10 de limitation à 50 % de capacité
de simuler ce qui a été fait dans les
autres pays c'est qu'ils ont confiné
mais d'une manière beaucoup moins
drastiques et draconiennes que chez nous
on les sent qu'un peu de souplesse ce
qu'il faut si vous voulez c'est ne pas
bloquer les entreprises parce qu'ils
l'entreprise son chiffre d'affaires ça
n'est pas viable sani pas vivable ça
n'est pas je dirais quelque chose qui va
nous amener
vers une une sauvegarde des entreprises
qu'ils soient plus importants excusez
moi je vous coupe je voudrais dire
alexandra dublanche ce que je vous ai vu
assez d'accord avec cette idée aussi que
les entreprises forcément ne sont pas
fait pour vivre des aides et qu'il faut
aussi qu'elle retrouve par la suite un
fonctionnement normal la question qui se
pose parce qu'on a passé à peu près la
moitié de l'ouverture de deux ce sky
business day nous reste à peu près une
demi heure des changes
la question qui se pose c'est le sait le
rebond aussi comment revenir à la
normale peut-on revenir à la normale et
puis est ce que cette crise va pouvoir
nous servir aussi à quelque chose est-ce
qu'il faut repenser le travail le
télétravail est ce que ce sera
pérennisée il ya beaucoup de questions
qui se posent aujourd'hui j'imagine que
aussi tant que responsable politique
vous vous la posez tout à fait alors
effectivement je rejoins tout à fait ce
qu'a dit zacharia redit les
entrepreneurs ils ne veulent pas d aide
ils veulent surtout travailler et c'est
la raison pour laquelle elle avait crès
on s'est beaucoup battu pour une
réouverture ou plutôt des commerces on
est assez désespérée pour les
restaurateurs qui comme disait sont en
grande difficulté en ile-de-france
ionnaires un tir qui pourrait mettre la
clé sous la porte c'est assez
catastrophique donc là aussi nous on
essaie de de s'adapter on est en train
de réfléchir à une aide pour les loyers
puisque c'est le gros sujet du moment et
que ce qui a été annoncé par l'êta de
crédit d'impôt bénéficiera certainement
au bayer mais pas au petit coiffeur qui
doit son successeur donc on est en train
de réfléchir à ces avec la présidente
effectivement moi je trouve que aussi on
a pas on n'a pas toujours été les plus
dans l'anticipation au niveau national
et que d'autres pays s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux
je pense par exemple si au sujet des
salons professionnels qui assouvissent
avec tous les vêtements ciel des grandes
difficultés et on est en train de perdre
des salons historiques qui se situait
ici dans notre région le salon de l'auto
qui est parti en allemagne et c'est
assez catastrophique et moi je suis
libéral je pousse pour qu'on fasse plus
confiance aux professionnels est un
professionnel de salon un commerçant
c'est très bien comment gérer son flux
et comment accueillir les personnes dans
la plus grande le plus grand respect des
conditions sanitaires
franchement moi je ça commence à
vraiment un peux m'énerver et je me
réjouis évidemment que les commerces
seraient au mot sur weekend
alors pour répondre à votre question
nous évidemment pense aussi à l'avenir
alors il ya certaines aides qui
contribue quand l'industrie on a un
prisme industrielle avec la présidente
bien avant cette crise ou et notamment
c'est peut-être notre origine blinoise
qui nous y pousse mais en tout cas on
est très attentif à ce qui se passe
effectivement dans l'automobile
l'aéronautique ont été hier matin avec
les répliques restent chez renault à
flins avec le président directeur
général de renault qui présentaient leur
projet justement voilà l'exemple de
renault est assez intéressant il ya de
grandes difficultés
et pour toute la chaîne de sous
traitance comment réfléchir à l'avenir
et proposer quelque chose qu'il ya de la
valeur ajoutée et donc là ils
s'entendent réfléchir à la création
d'une filière de retrofit delà du
recyclage des véhicules pour être
compétitif par rapport à des véhicules
électriques produits en asie qui arrive
sur nos marchés qui sont évidemment bien
moins cher donc c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et récemment on a aussi aidé la
présente l'a rappelé par exemple dans
des grands projets industriels ce qui
nous est reproché d'ailleurs par notre
position parce que ce sont des grands
groupes attention mais pas l'homme ont
bien d'aider airbus
justement à elancourt ce jeu ne trompe
pas où il est tout à fait et air france
sur le travail sur le moteur du futur le
moteur plus écologique
comment mais moins de silicone dans les
cartes électroniques et donc c'est des
projets comme ça aussi le cantique où on
a des beaux projets dans les yvelines
avec recul et souvent avec atos par
exemple et donc aussi investir dans
l'avenir comme ça dans l'avenir cette
industrie ou qu'elle réussisse à se
transformer et passer cette fameuse
industrie 4.0 donc évidemment qu'on
regarde l'avenir il y aller des mesures
conjoncturelles de crise d'essayer de
répondre aux problèmes de trésorerie et
puis à tous les investissements beaucoup
plus structurelle pour l'avenir de notre
industrie pour la rendre encore plus
attractif jean michel fourgous pour
l'agglomération c'est à dire vous vous
écoutez aussi les entreprises qui auront
sans doute de nouveau besoin pour la
suite nommé alexandre a raison de
rappeler qu' il y a des nouveaux process
qui apparaissent dans la production d'un
service est évident qu'il ya des
habitudes de travail qui se sont
modernisés
et c'est vrai que cette crise dit
quelqu'un dramatique mais aura des côtés
positifs dans certains secteurs
je vous prends un exemple l'éducation
aujourd'hui nos élèves ont beaucoup plus
d'autonomie pour apprendre en fait
qu'avant ils ont il ya une progression
de cette fameuse pédagogie mixte une
partie présentiel à l'école et une
partie distant ciel à domicile il ya eu
un saut j'irai de culturelle
extraordinaire
bon il ya des entreprises on va bien ils
ont modernisé leurs process de
fabrication
donc bien sûr d'abord il ya au dos des
limons produire même sur l'île vous la
sentez vous avez une chute des grippes
ah bon vous avez une chute d'un seul
angle de malades x tarbes ont alors
enfin sonné c'est un comptage un peu un
peu triste bien sûr à faire entre les
plus les moins mais se dit bien sûr
qu'il y à il y à des avances même nos
commerçants nos commerçants qui
n'étaient pas très e-commerce il ya eu
une progression passait seul un an les
push vous et nous on est au point des
formations pour augmenter
l'employabilité numérique pour que
vraiment ils sont encore plus mais je
dirais que je vous rappelle plus
numérique est le premier facteur de
réussite de demain d'un pays ce sera le
niveau numérique d'un pays qui
déterminera son pib et donc son niveau
de compétitivité dans le monde l'a donc
tout cela
tout cela bien sûr va dans le bon sens
je veux simplement dire que mais même
dans ce même dans le système hospitalier
quand je dis que la leur le centre des
entrepreneurs mais sur cd grande vedette
aujourd'hui parce que c'est eux qui
tiennent ici et puis des finances pour
financer nos hôpitaux dotés de traduire
de télévision donc voilà il faut faut
bien remettre tous les tous les noms
d'acteurs qui ont travaillé ensemble
dans ces crises on voit effectivement
que les français sont dire jamais
meilleurs que lorsqu'ils ont le dos au
mur ce camp mais qu'il les guide et
environs de la vérifier
on l'a vérifié franchement n'oublie pas
on n'oublie pas le travail sanitaire je
veux dire cette exceptionnelle n'oublie
pas tous les acteurs des services
d'urgence et des armes ont eux mêmes
l'état même l'état bon il ya des gens et
des gens merveilleux et des gens
formidables or il faut bien qu'ils
aillent dire aux gens qui le sont moins
qui sont un peu plus attendre il
faudrait que bien sûr dans cette taille
il y aussi une révolution culturelle qui
n'est pas encore fait mais qui a aussi
bouger il ya des gens des acteurs qui se
sont bien mieux compris l'entreprise et
tout un discours quelques fois en six
entreprises français qui est
insupportable d'ailleurs mais bon
10 même ça il y a eu je pense si une
progression à comprendre le rôle de
l'entreprise le rôle social le rôle un
jeu rappelle que l'état prend 50 %
quasiment d'impôts en sociales et
fiscales sur le live c'est ce que prône
une entreprise bon voilà je crois que
les gens ça peut être aussi réconcilier
un centre de choses voilà et puis qui
m'ont montré que quelques fonds savaient
pas à quoi servait une région et
département une aide le mince je pense
que les gens ont aussi progressé à mieux
comprendre quand la france était
attaquée comme cela voilà il ya quand
même quelque part a demandé de tout le
monde travaille ensemble
gera bachevalier pour la cci sur cette
idée de rebondir de repenser peut-être
le travail par la suite
du côté des des entreprises aussi
peut-être plus d'un recours au
télétravail est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut généralisé ou pas quel
regard vous avez sur ces questions là où
sur les attentes aussi que vous pouvez
avoir d'abord je voudrais revenir avec
jean wadoux blanche concernant les
salons il est il est vrai que
actuellement étant donné que les sangles
de salon n'ont pas pu se tenir
en ile-de-france il ya beaucoup de
salons qui se sont tenues à l'étranger
et je pense que pour un certain nombre
d'années on risque de perdre justement
des que des salons puisse se
tenir justement sur sur l'île de france
et je jeu sadique conséquences sur toute
la partie entreprise d'événementiel qui
qui travaillent dans le cadre de ces
savons donc c'est vrai que c'est une une
complication de ceux de ce type
d'activité et j'espère que l'on pourra
retrouver justement des salons
importants et al sahili a des talents
qui se sont tenues en allemagne ou en
asie alors qu'ils n'avaient pas pu se
tenir en france et ça c'est bien dommage
pour revenir justement à votre question
concernant le rebond et et la façon de
retrouver une activité
je pense à mon tout qu'il faut tirer les
leçons de cette crise c'est à dire qu'il
faut réfléchir à un nouveau modèle
économique sur les territoires on s'est
rendu compte que
e la problématique des déplacements et
des dés des open space posait un
problème justement dans pour les
entreprises le développement du
télétravail a été quelque chose de très
positif mais qui peut être aussi négatif
parce que telle et travailler chez soi
ce n'est pas non plus une solution
je pense qu'il faut trouver d'autres
modèles de télétravail avec des des
solutions au partage et de télétravail à
des espaces de coworking qui se
développe de plus en plus mais pas
suffisamment en grande couronne je pense
qu'il faut développer ce télétravail
avoir une vision un peu différente du
modèle économique en essayant d'éviter
justement les déplacements actuellement
en ile-de-france et 40% des salariés qui
sont à moins de 5 km de leur entreprise
donc je pense qu'il faut et il faut
savoir aussi qu' à 227 mille salariés
qui sortent chaque jour des yvelines
pour aller travailler sur paris ou sur
la défense je pense que c'est ce ne pas
non plus un modèle économique qui qu'ils
soient valables pour pour l'avenir je
pense qu'il faut réfléchir justement sur
une nouvelle industrie sur une nouvelle
répartition des activités sur les
territoires et essayer encore une fois
de tirer les leçons de la crise pour
réorganiser justement l'activité sur le
territoire et là dans les yvelines en a
un potentiel important puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de zones d'activité ce qui
manque un petit peu c'est des fois les
transports on va reparler de la ligne 18
qui ne manquent sur saint quentin et qui
va arriver un peu tard mais on a besoin
de transport bien sûr mais aussi on a
besoin de revoir complètement
par exemple nos zones d'activités qui
sont pas suffisamment attractif donc là
la tue moi j'ai je souhaiterais qu'il
des zones d'activités qui se
renouvellent qui soit plus attractive
qui propose des services communs comme
dans la conciergerie pour les justement
les petites et les petites entreprises
en particulier des outils partage et
d'imprimantes 3d du matériel de test
justement numérique d
des zones d'activités qu'ils soient
autonomes en énergie
une animation dans ces zones d'activités
de la formation par exemple des managers
de grande activité qui crée le lien
entre les différentes entreprises parce
que il faut aussi arriver à une
collaboration entre entreprises en a vu
qu'il y avait la possibilité pendant
cette crise sanitaire de d'entreprise
qui travaillaient ensemble et qui
pourrait justement produire produire
ensemble des produits très très très
utile justement pour pour la crise
sanitaire et je pense qu'il faut
continuer il faut créer ce lien
important entre les grandes entreprises
les tpe pme qui existent en partie mais
qu'il faut encore développer
et puis il ya des potentiels
d'innovation dans le numérique dans
différents métiers les la crise a touché
fortement nos deux principales filières
que sont l'automobile l'aéronautique
elles ont besoin aussi de deux je dirais
de se reconfigurer de travailler
différemment peut-être et puis il faut
qu'on accompagne toutes les tpe pme qui
sont sous traitants de l'industrie c'est
l'industrie avant tout qu'ils créent et
qui crée la richesse d'un territoire et
qui permet après au commerce de se
développer
il ya aussi le tourisme qui a été très
touché et qu'il faut qu'on aide il faut
qu'on accompagne et ça tout ça le le
commerce vie justement parce qu'il ya du
tourisme parce que il ya de la richesse
économique par l'industrie donc il faut
appuyer cette industrie et essayer de la
faire évoluer vers le nouveau métier
vous parler de ses relations entre les
grands groupes les plus petits groupes
ce travail en commun c'est bien là tout
l'objet du sky business des bien
évidemment qu ici aujourd'hui et je vous
le rappelle si vous venez nous rejoindre
que nous sommes à la table ronde
d'ouverture de cette initiative de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette année
100 % numérique vous aviez longuement
parlé dans votre intervention gérard
bacheliers des zones d'activités je vais
revenir dans un instant je voudrais
juste voir avec vous acquérez hardy pour
le medef pour la suite pour le rebond ce
que vous vous dites aussi c'est qu'il va
pas falloir fixer trop de règles non
plus enfin les un peu de liberté à ses
entrepreneurs du jeu de revenir sur 1
ce qu'a dit alexander du blanche
concernant l'investissement
l'investissement effectivement il va
falloir le soutenir fortement parce que
les entreprises vont sortir de cette
crise
endetté avec un affaiblissement
important de leur trésorerie
donc il faut les accompagner les aider
et c'est vrai j'ai assisté à une très
belle intervention de la région avec aux
côtés d'alexandra dublanche c'était la
société kb distribution très belle start
up
elle a vu le jour la sarthe rebelles
voilà à sartrouville grâce à l'aide et à
l'assistance de la région je tiens
vraiment à le saluer il est vrai que
aujourd'hui le mode de travail a
considérablement changé parce par le
télétravail mais nous insistons
aujourd'hui à une dérive qui consiste en
fait à réglementer le télétravail et à
l'europe peut être plus contraignant
peut-être le rendre un petit peu rendre
le coût du travail un peu plus élevé
nous au sein du medef
nous disons qu'il faut laisser
l'entreprise organisé le télétravail
organisées en fonction des spécificités
des services des spécificités des
besoins des spécificités également des
salariés parce qu'il y en a certains qui
se sont bien dans le télétravail à
d'autres mais surtout il faut pas le
contraindre le rendre plus cher pourquoi
parce que quelqu'un qui est eric qui
télétravaillent et 10 km de télétravail
est à 20 km 300 km mais peut aussi aller
travailler à 1000 kilomètres donc
faisant très attention à ce que nous ne
souhaitons faire se faisant très
attention à la réglementation qu'on
voudrait imposer aux entreprises
laissons les choses sont organisées en
fonction des besoins et laissons un peu
de souplesse surtout évitons d'augmenter
le coût de travail
encore une fois en france jean michel
fourgous pour revenir sur la question
des zones cno zone d'activité sauf si
vous souhaitez bien évidemment rebondir
sur ce qui vient d'être dit mais sur les
zones d'activités on entendu aussi une
certaine demande de la part de la cci
des moderniser et dynamiser repenser ça
fait aussi partie du travail un peu de
la réflexion de l'agglomération sur le
sur le secteur en tout cas sur le
télétravail pour répondre
entre collègues sac du medef je dirais
que ce qu'on a vu nous saint quentin
saint quentin et laon course à saint
quentin a obtenu le premier prix
national pendant cette crise
on leur a soumis le vieux les vends donc
le prix de dudu de la delà de la lutte
et les traces du télétravail scolaire
entre guillemets et donc le plus fictive
et le plus efficacement
cela dit et donc ça nous rend au
télétravail en entreprise dont parle ac
et
effectivement alors c'est pas ça dépend
des activités il d'ailleurs il faut bien
il faut pas il faut être conscient que
les entreprises ça marche très bien et
d'autres d'autres sas doute ça marche
moins bien et de sa marche pas du tout
bon donc non en tout cas c'est un mode
il ya une étude sur 131 pays qui a été
fait ou ont demandé quelle a été la
meilleure mesure la plus efficace contre
le coc vide c'est le télétravail qui a
été cité bon donc une grosse étude
internationale bon donc voilà il faut
réfléchir
cela dit les français vont quand même
s'engager massivement les entreprises de
son entame en mai c'est à suivre je
pense qu'il faudra entre tous les
acteurs qui sont présents d'ailleurs sur
cette table ronde ce soit la ccx mais
des foules et bien sûr les organismes
comme la région il est évident qu'il
faudra qu'on se dise de la législation
il n'est pas question qu'on continue
dans ce pays acp a paralysé le pays a
laissé des gens qui n'ont pas
d'expérience il n'y a pas de compétence
en expérience dit le partout donc il
n'est pas possible que quelqu'un touche
à une loi française s'il n'a pas une
expérience
bon c'est pas parce que vous êtes
brillant intellectuellement que vous
êtes compétent la compétence et
l'expérience qu'il est valide mans donc
il faut des lois faites par des gens de
terrain a priori des entrepreneurs sont
des gens qui sont particulièrement ils
sont déjà selon vous disparaissez ce
n'est pas le sérieux de terrain
entreprises - donc voila moi je je je
renforce tout à fait c'est très
important ce qu'il dit vous m'aviez dit
là sur les zones d'activités aussi
également et sur le travail que vous
pouvez mener les réflexions les échanges
que vous pouvez avoir avec les
entreprises est ce qu'il ya des
réflexions des pistes des choses à
améliorer aussi des par les transports
aussi tout ça font partie toutes ces
compétences font partie des choses que
gère aussi une agglomération premier
tales en un dirigeant c'est savoir
choisir les talents j'ai un service de
développement économique
ou bien sûr il ya des gens de talent sur
notamment à une faille qui réussissent
avec une extrême efficacité et qui a su
recruter aussi des gens donc on a une
heure aujourd'hui un service
développement économique à 51,10 on est
obligé on a dix sept nuits en 2060 voilà
c'est notre première c'est notre
première compétence ça fonctionne et
c'est eux qui entretiennent un réseau un
réseau de relations
oui avec des relais enfin la cession
fait partie d'hier la région le medef
les toutes les institutions les clubs
d'entreprises aussi qu'ils sont aussi
présents c'est vrai de delta cela de
convergence et c'est ce réseau qu'il
faut entretenir en ce moment faut pas le
lâcher parce que derrière il y est voilà
il décline ce que dix sept mille peut
pas les voir tous les jours ensemble
vous en doutez donc cesser ce réseau qui
sait de compétences que qu'on s'est
déclinée qu'on sait animer et ça je le
dire pour l'instant ça fonctionne bien
avec les soutiens sur deux partenaires
puissants qui sont présents c'est ça qui
fonctionne il nous reste une dizaine de
minutes pour conclure cette table ronde
du sky business day cette ouverture dans
ce cas business verra les i j'ai oublié
sky emploie aussi emploi.fr il ya
vingt-cinq mille cd qui se sont inscrits
donc que les gens continuent parce que
au moment de la relance qui quand même a
priori c'est en train de se débloquer
quand même un mois deux mois je pense
que je pense j'en suis pas sûr à 100%
mais voilà donc ne pas oublier de mettre
son cv plus possible alexandre a dit
blanc si on a un message d'espoir à
passer aussi aux entrepreneurs peut-être
pour conclure cette table ronde se
serait ce serait quoi c'est justement de
se dire que la crise sera peut-être
bientôt fini en tout cas dans un premier
temps puisqu'il faudra rebondir ensuite
eh oui effectivement l'arrivée du vaccin
en l'espère est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle et nous on continuera à se
mobiliser là dessus puisque on a été
aussi fort soutien surtout l'aspect
sanitaire la région près de l'état
je voulais dire ça ça rebondit un peu
sur ce qu'il vient de dire c'est que
cette crise
bon ben il ya tout un évidement de
conséquences extrêmement négative ni
aussi certaines opportunités qui
émergent
vous voyez quand on parle de télétravail
quand on parle de numérisation des
commerces
quand on parle de numérisation au niveau
de l'éducation nous c'est des mouvements
qu'on a essayé d' enclenché depuis
plusieurs années à la région et on avait
honnêtement du mal on avait mis nous en
place le télétravail à la région prend
pas on a déménagé à saint pois on a mis
on a mis nos agents au télétravail à
deux jours par semaine et ces points que
les grandes entreprises de faire de même
on n'y arrivait pas bon mais là il ya un
mouvement qui s'enclenche qui est
important parce que à plusieurs titres
le télétravail c'est évidemment un gain
en qualité de vie on évite deux heures
de transport et c'est aussi faire
travailler l'activité locale puisque si
je suis là aujourd'hui à sartrouville
par exemple je vais aller déjeuner à
sartrouville dans les restaurants seront
ouverts à nouveau et pas à la défense
par exemple et donc du coup je fais
vivre aussi l'activité locale le
commerce local
c'est extrêmement important ce qui a été
travaillé aussi après une crise comme ça
qu'il y en a vu aussi des franciliens
partir hors de la région il faut qu'on
reste une région attractive et donc faut
gagner en qualité de vie
donc c'est important et c'est pour ça
qu'on finance énormément tiers lieux
notamment grande couronne ça améliore
aussi des transports puisque quand il ya
moins de monde dans les transports
forcément l'expérience est un peu
meilleur sur la numérisation des
commerces exactement la même chose on
avait lancé avec les cci à deux ans le
chèque numérique pour aider à la
numérisation des commerces et ça prenait
pas vraiment d'ampleur et là évidemment
les commerces se rendent compte
maintenant que c'est important pas
seulement contexte de crise mais après
pour faire face à la concurrence des
grandes surfaces
donc ce sont des mouvements
d'opportunités l'industrie aussi que
peut-être est un peu bousculé avance à
marche forcée mais du coup on voit des
des relocalisations de bout de chaîne de
production vois moi je le vois dans les
rues ou nautiques dans les projets qu'on
a financé dans l'automobile et donc tout
ça c'est aussi de belles perspectives
pour preuve notre région pour notre
territoire d éviter donc je sa c2
voilà le petit rayon de soleil dans la
période actuelle
jara bacheliers également il faut rester
positif je rejoins totalement ce que
vient de dire avec sandra du blanche
la situation a été difficile c'était une
crise importante grave pour les
entreprises et pour l'activité
économique mais il faut en tirer encore
une fois et je pense qu'il faut en tirer
des leçons et des dispositifs ont été
mises en place d habitude nouvelles ont
été mises en place effectivement les
commerçants était difficile c'était
difficile d'intéresser les commerçants
numérique et maintenant ils sont
intéressés au numérique et j'espère
qu'ils vont rester justement accroché à
ce numérique qui peut les aider
justement comme complètement de le
chiffre d'affaires il est important
aussi que les entreprises retrouvent du
chiffre d'affaires et puisse
retravailler normalement donc le vaccin
d'un espoir d'une activité qui qui va
reprendre
mais ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils vous
pas oublié je pense c'est que on doit
repenser un petit peu l'activité est
encore une fois je pense
il faudrait prendre un peu de hauteur et
définir une stratégie territoriale donc
par territoire les yvelines c'est un
département qui est différent par
exemple de la seine et marne donc avec
une liste à l'historique industrielle il
faut repenser la stratégie revoir
justement comment on peut aider les
entreprises à rebondir donc désespoir
c'est un espoir effectivement de pouvoir
rebondir facilement suite à cette crise
sanitaire et j'espère justement qu'on
pourra travailler ensemble pour aider
les entreprises et en particulier dont
que l'industrie / sur le territoire a
retrouvé une activité suffisante sa
carrière d pour le medef également
quelques mots de conclusion
oui je dirais que les entreprises ont
besoin d'un effectif et ils ont besoin
d'eux
dead pour sortir de cette crise et aller
vers et aller de l'avant
le medef a mis en place un comité
d'experts pour accompagner les
entrepreneurs qui sont en difficulté ou
qui ont besoin des deux pour je dirais
remettre leur entreprise sur de bons
rails
ce sont des entrepreneurs au service
d'autres entrepreneurs et en s'appuyant
sur nos centres de centaines de
mandataires dans le département et dans
la région également nos relations avec
les chefs des différents services de
l'état la préfecture la direccte la dg
fille les services fiscaux etc etc
voilà donc nous sommes là pour
accompagner aider et permettre aux
entrepreneurs de reprendre de l'espoir
travail en commun entre les entreprises
des territoires jean michel fourgous
pour conclure cette table ronde
d'ouverture du ska business des écoutes
et voilà c'est fait pour nos
entrepreneurs assez fait pour qu'ils
augmentent leur chiffre d'affaires qui
le maintiennent le mieux possible bien
sûr qu'ils aient encore plus de clients
qu'ils améliorent leurs relations sur
avec leurs clients ou 6 avec une
relation fournisseurs vue d'améliorer
toute la chaîne qui fait la richesse
d'une entreprise l'a réussi dans eurobus
bon on est là on va pas tout résoudre
mais je peux vous dire tous les acteurs
qui sont là ils ont joué leur rôle
d'ailleurs j'aurais simplement dire il
félicité parce que on a réappris je
crois qu'on aurait appris le rôle à quoi
servaient les médecins pas donc d'une
fois on savait plus là à quoi ça va un
entrepreneur quoi savez tous les
services d'urgence 1 je crois que il ya
peut-être eu en même temps dans cette
crise qui va nous coûter quand même plus
de cinquante mille morts dire qu'il ya
des choses où chacun a retrouvé une
place a compris aquasar des l'autre on
l'avait oublié
voilà je enverra les études qui seront
faites dans les mois à venir si ce
vaccin bien sûr et sédition je le pense
qu'il le sera
écoutez voilà il y aura il y aura de
très mauvais côté faut pas les flux pas
signé on le sait mais mais je pense que
c'est peut-être maintenant le rebond
puisque l'économie s'est sans cesse du
rebond et on le voit dans nos
entrepreneurs de saint quentin il ya
comme un esprit de rebond ils
l'attendent
on est là pour obvier sur le l'accélérer
voilà donc je pense qu'il ya aussi des
choses positives
merci jean michel fourgous président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci
également alexandre à 10 branches
dublanche la vice-présidente de l'île de
france chargé du développement
économique merci à vous merci sa
carrière dit président du medef yvelines
et à gérard bacheliers président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles merci à tous les cas merci
aussi à mary pécresse qui est intervenue
au début de cette émission le sky
business day se poursuit uniquement en
ligne cette année puis ce soir dans le
journal de tv 78 à 18h en direct nous
ferons un premier bilan avec alexandra
rosetti elle est en charge des dossiers
économiques pour l'agglomération de 50
ans très bonne journée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]